you're a black belt in jiu jitsu but
more importantly you've beaten a lot of
world-class jiu-jitsu people
you've done very well at the highest
levels of competition yeah i wouldn't
necessarily say i've beaten them as much
as
i've trained with them
and
they understand whoever it is that
through training with me
that like i'm not just a judo guy
like i know how to do jiu jitsu
right and
if any one of them were to come to me
and like
say hey
you know
i want to feel what it feels like to do
judo with me
they would quickly understand that like
the way i approach one is very different
than the way i approach the other like
we probably wouldn't be friends if they
did judo with me versus if they did jiu
jitsu with me i'm curious asking for a
friend because mostly because i'll do a
little judo with you today
so you clearly because you're a great
instructor and teacher you have a mode
where you can demonstrate a technique
do you know how to like spar where
you're going like
50 percent
it's hard to put like a percentage to it
because
i've never in all of my jiu jitsu ever
gone 100
in jiu jitsu yeah like i had a
conversation with salo one time
where we were talking about like
jiu jitsu and training and i was like
well if i got his arm i would just break
it
and he was like
but what if he tapped i go that's not my
responsibility
if he taps and the ref doesn't say
anything you just break it you just keep
going yeah he goes but the tap means
it's over and i said no the ref tells me
when it's over i go
i never give you the opportunity to tap
because if you have the opportunity to
tap that means you had the opportunity
to think about how to get out make a
decision that you can't
then tap i clearly operated too slowly
yeah so there's a it's either broken or
i don't have it
you're a terrifying person to go against
in judo like the on the ground like
everything you did that's that's amazing
um
that's really amazing that's what made
you a really fun person to watch
because you really went to war with
these people yeah
so you know what it's like to go 100 in
judo i do because i know
what it's like to
train with somebody under the mentality
of
i'm going to do everything i want to do
you're going to do nothing you want to
do and you're going to accept that
do you ever train in judo where where
you let people get stuff of course
all the time
now or like always
even when you're sort of building up the
four years building up to the olympics
like they're smaller guys that are
throwing you in the gym and that kind of
stuff no i never said that okay
that never came out of my mouth
i said i let people do stuff i never
said smaller people throw me oh you mean
you let him get a grip but then you'll
position yourself in such a way that
it's it's hopeless it's like
the number one skill set that
judo is going to teach you is
the ability to give people false hope
right because i can really looking
forward to the video we're going to
shoot
like i can let you take a grip yeah i
can let you think that there's
opportunity but what you don't
understand is by the position and angle
that i'm in
it's actually false hope yeah like
as long as you don't know that it is
then now i'm free to operate and do what
i want
you